Western games don't come around that
often apart from a few indie games the
market has been dry to be honest it
never really flourished sure there have
been standout games from time to time
but it's never really caught on
maybe that's because Wild West
properties aren't very lucrative maybe
it's because the error was rife with
sensitive issues like the Indian Wars
and the Chinese Exclusion Act or perhaps
it's because Rockstar set a very high
bar with a little game called Red Dead
Redemption
[Music]
[Music]
believe it or not Red Dead Redemption
was not the first Red Dead game if you
saw the initial reaction to Red Dead
Redemption - Strahler than you probably
noticed a few people taking issue with
the title technically the first game in
this series is Red Dead Revolver in
order to do this history of video
justice we need to turn back the clocks
to the early 2000s Red Dead Revolver was
originally produced by Capcom and
developed by Angel Studios as a
spiritual successor to the arcade game
Gunsmoke the game was announced in 2002
and they can't be over-the-top trailer
was shown at e3 that year there are even
some shots of Cowboys flying around a
battlefield and enemies labeled as
Wizards but that game never saw the
light of day after its initial reveal
the project went quiet
this was allegedly due to development
issues Red Dead Revolver was unplayable
and lacked a clear direction Capcom
decided to cancel Red Dead Revolver
about a year after it was announced but
hope was not lost
rockstars parent company take-two
acquired angel studios for twenty eight
million dollars in cash and renamed the
studio Rockstar San Diego Angel Studios
and Rockstar already had a good
relationship leading up to the
acquisition most notably the two Studios
work together on Smuggler's run and
midnight club both of which debuted in
2000 shortly after Rockstar purchased
angel studios executives reviewed its
projects most were tossed out but one
game caught the eye of dan Houser
rockstars creative director that game
was Red Dead Revolver
[Music]
despite the game's troubled development
rock star gave San Diego the go-ahead
and development picked up once again on
May 4th 2004 Red Dead Revolver released
on Xbox and PlayStation 2 although the
game appears to share a lot of the same
assets as the Capcom produced version
you can see rockstars influence on the
final release while still Arkady the
game was more mature and put a strong
emphasis on the narrative you play as
red Harlow a Clint Eastwood type seeking
revenge after bandits killed this family
throughout the course of your journey
you hunt outlaws and track down the man
who murdered your parents the story
hasn't aged well
the pacing is off most of the characters
are two-dimensional and the quality of
voice acting varies I'm going to make
main screen out of you however it does
have that Rockstar feel it deals with
greed criticizes the American Dream and
of course it's bloody
revolver had a very different structure
than what would follow it rather than an
open-world it was a linear third-person
cover based shooter missions either fed
you through narrow passageways or
dropped you in a small arena to fight
off waves of enemies eventually leading
to a spongy boss fight in between these
missions you could visit a town called
brimstone which acted as a hub area you
could speak to different characters
visit shops pick up bounties and hang
out in the saloon it was a nice touch
that added a bit of character to the
game while in brimstone you could
purchase new maps and characters for the
multiplayer mode and journal entries
that filled in a bit of the backstory
there wasn't anything particularly
unique with its gameplay apart from the
Deadeye mechanic Deadeye allowed you to
slow time paint targets with red circles
and unleash a flurry of bullets it's a
fitting but shallow touch for a western
game all-in-all Red Dead Revolver is
your standard ps2 era third-person
shooter GameSpot gave it a 7.3 saying it
has some great style and enough fun to
justify the rough edges rather than
crafting something unique with its
western setting Red Dead Revolver is
more like a Greatest Hits of classic
western films set pieces and characters
felt as though they were pulled from
classics like the good bad and ugly and
the Wild Bunch while it had some fun
moments it didn't give you the freedom
some yearned for with a Western game a
year later Neversoft the developers
behind the Tony Hawk series tried to
fill that void with a game called gun
not Kingdom God
that I will be done gun promised to be
that open world cowboy experience fans
of the genre were hoping for however the
story was brief and once you completed
it there wasn't much to do
never soft gave us a taste of an
open-world game but ultimately fell
short meanwhile Rockstar put the red
dead IP on the backburner and Rockstar
San Diego shifted its efforts to the
midnight club series well kind of
[Music]
development for the follow-up began in
2005 one year after revolver released
but this time Rockstar San Diego said
its expectations higher much higher the
team set out to make an atmospheric
Western game with a believable
open-world setting that game was called
Red Dead Redemption Rockstar would use
the rage engine the same one used for
Grand Theft Auto 4 and rockstars
table-tennis but due to the game's large
open areas the team needed to tweak the
engine to fit the direction of the
project the development team consisted
of eight hundred members spanning the
globe and it was estimated to cost
eighty to a hundred million dollars
making it one of the most expensive
games ever made despite all its
resources Red Dead Redemption z'
development wasn't without its fair
share of obstacles for one the map was
huge and seamless redemption wasn't
confined to a city like GTA 4 this meant
that draw distances needed to be greatly
improved on top of that the team needed
to find ways to make these large
expanses interesting the world needed to
be filled with mystery points of
interest and things to do however his
production continued more and more
issues began to spring up in January
2009 just 5 months before the game was
scheduled to release and gadget broke a
story about redemptions troubled State
one source even said it was a complete
disaster for most of 2009 in previous it
has since turned around a little bit but
there are huge problems with it still it
wasn't until 2016 that more light was
shed on the situation former Rockstar
North President Leslie Benzies filed a
150 million dollar lawsuit against
rockstars parent company take 2 after he
was allegedly forced out during the
lawsuit his legal team was trying to
prove how vital he was in the production
of Red Dead Redemption according to the
story Sam Houser emailed Leslie Benzies
in 2009 asking for his assistance saying
that Red Dead Redemption is a recurring
nightmare and begging Benzies to help
the game get back on track Rockstar San
Diego seemed to lack a clear direction
and desperately needed someone with
oversight and strong managerial skills
despite all these issues Red Dead
Redemption was only delayed once for a
few weeks on May 18th 2010 Red Dead
Redemption was released on Xbox 360 and
ps3 and was met with over
praise red Harlow was replaced with the
much more complex and nuanced John
Marston after walking away from his gang
Marston must kill or capture his old
partner Bill Williamson in order to
clear his name
unfortunately this thrust him back into
the world he tried to escape once again
this game plays with the expectations of
the American Dream and the dangers of
capitalism wall exploring themes such as
greed technology violence and
expansionism that they are finally
bringing civilization to this he'll be
looking down on us please help the
natives yes they've lost their land but
they've gained access to heaven despite
its obvious influences Redemption
crafted an epic story of its own unlike
revolver redemption took cues from
modern Western media like the Unforgiven
in Deadwood there's even an area in the
game named after daniel plainview the
protagonist of there will be blood this
resulted in a far more complex narrative
than its predecessor what's going on
here I got me warning Williamson boys I
got me one of them idiots who give
marshals a bad name done' put your gun
down characters had motivations there
was no clear delineation between good
and evil
unless you count Marsten's undercooked
morality meter and there were very few
characters you could trust
however these characters are all still
so memorable like the well-spoken con
artist nigel west dickens aimed the
grave robbing junkie seth and all of
this built up to arguably one of the
best endings in a video game Bill
Williamson
come out here right now Redemption was
also one of rockstars first open-world
games to really get its shooting
mechanics right holding down the trigger
halfway allowed you to free aim and
holding it down all the way let you
softlock onto targets it wasn't perfect
but it felt much better than gta4
Rockstar later refined these same
shooting mechanics in Max Payne 3 and
GTA 5 and let's not forget about the
lasso and this game's almost too real
physics engine Rockstar got a lot right
with Red Dead Redemption but it's
setting an atmosphere proved to be one
of its most impressive feats spanning
the barren deserts of Mexico to the
snow-covered peaks of the US you are
free to roam a beautiful realistic
recreation of the West accompanied by a
fantastic soundtrack
[Music]
stay
so far
edge
[Music]
you could hunt bounties cheat at poker
break horses hunt wildlife and duel
other outlaws Rockstar gave players the
tools to live out their Wild West
fantasies you could even carry out these
fantasies online with Red Dead
Redemption multiplayer component it was
just as ambitious as the single-player
allowing you to form gangs with other
players and roam the world completing
bounty missions and hunting down other
players this mode accrued a respectable
following but there was a lot to be
desired
the world was a bit empty and
progression felt tedious there was
certainly something special about it but
Red Dead Redemption online didn't quite
live up to the expertly crafted and
masterfully written single-player mode
you know we've nude here for 30 years
now came here from the East land had
never been settled for 10 years we
fought the Indians tough men then we had
outlaws who had drought we had smallpox
terrible winters Colorado I'm very more
my children I raised I'm sorry to hear
that sir I've seen strong men wither and
die under that unforgiving Sun
that whole herd the cattle take sick and
died but I've never once doubted my life
here no sir
rockstar wasn't quite ready to move on
from Red Dead Redemption
less than a year after it came out
Rockstar released Red Dead Redemption
undead nightmare just in time for
Halloween
the world was given a sinister makeover
and John Marston was back to find a cure
for his zombified wife for the most part
Red Dead Redemption took itself
seriously but within seconds rockstar
paints a very different picture with
undead nightmare after mom's away John
Marston has returned to his loved ones
while trying to rebuild his ranch and
win back the trust of his family it paid
homage to campy B horror films the DLC
also added new weapons and the rad
horses of the Apocalypse players were
tasked with defending different
settlements and clearing out zombie
infestation z' in order to unlock new
missions and progress through the story
to no one's surprise undead nightmare
was met with critical acclaim as well
the gameplay loop did get repetitive
after a while asking you to return to
settlements often to protect them from
zombies but the lengthy story and
refreshing setting was more than enough
to return to that world they have dogs
going crazy wolves howling birds flying
it's just a storm down over the next
couple years Rockstar continued to
support the game with DLC for
redemptions multiplayer but once it ran
its course the team moved over to other
projects
[Music]
until 2014 Rockstar released a game
every year in 2011 we got LA noire an
open-world detective game set in the
1940s and in 2012 it resurrected Max
Payne with Max Payne 3 and finally in
2013 the highly anticipated grand theft
auto 5 hit shelves and in 2014 it came
to Xbox one and ps4 just recently
take-two revealed that GTA 5 has sold
over 90 million copies since then
Rockstar hasn't released another game
instead they've been supporting GTA
online with constant updates though GTA
online continues to be a huge success
many fans missed rockstars high-quality
single-player content but the developer
was silent in 2015 and 2016 rumors
started to spread that rockstar was
working on a follow up to Red Dead
Redemption something they neither
confirmed nor denied that is until
October 18th 2016 Rockstar revealed that
there was indeed a Red Dead Redemption 2
and followed the announcement with a
trailer a few days later when the time
comes
you gotta run and on the back
this is over
the game was scheduled to release in
fall 2017 but as you know that didn't
happen the game got delayed until spring
2018 to make up for it
Rockstar gave us a flashy new trailer
and introduced us to the new playable
character Arthur Morgan
unfortunately Red Dead Redemption too
missed its spring release window and is
now scheduled for October 26 2018 we
don't know much about redemption sequel
but it will take place around the same
time as the first and feature familiar
characters like Dutch and possibly Bill
Williamson all we can do now is wait but
considering rockstars track record I
don't think we have much to worry about
though the series had a rough start with
a Red Dead Revolver Red Dead Redemption
set a precedent for not only all
rockstar games moving forward but all
open-world games
it took the open-world formula that rock
star itself pioneered and pushed it to
the next level
they built a highly detailed handcrafted
open-world that felt alive it told a
deep complex story with the confidence
and style of some of the best film
directors and of course it laid down the
foundation for rockstars most ambitious
and successful game to date for Red Dead
Redemption 2 to push the boundaries as
much as its predecessor is a big ask but
if there's any developer that can pull
it off its Rockstar
[Music]